[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi there.
My name is Ibrahim Elbouchikhi.
I'm a product manager on
the Google Play Store.
And today I want to talk to you
about what's new in Google Play
app discovery.
Be together, not the same.
This is the Android campaign
that's going on right now.
It signifies the diversity
of the ecosystem-- the fact
that our users stem from so
many different countries,
speak different languages,
have different interests,
use different
devices, et cetera.
And this particular diversity
makes it both a challenge
and an opportunity for us
to build a great discovery
experience.
So I'm going to tell you
a bit more about it today.
But first, I want to
quantify this diversity.
We have over a billion users.
They come from over 190
countries, speak 63 languages,
and issue over 400 million
unique search terms each month.
Now think about that again.
These are 400
million search terms.
Different interests, different
queries, different needs,
different questions.
The user coming to
the Play Store to find
apps that they could satisfy.
So that's really exciting to
us, and that just signifies,
again, the diversity
of the ecosystem.
With an ecosystem this
diverse, how do you
enable organic discovery?
We think of it in three buckets.
First is enabling
discovery through search.
Search is one of the
key ways that users
discover apps on Google Play.
Second is personalizing
the browse experience.
And finally, it's about
enabling exploration,
which is slightly different
than personalization,
as I'll get into later.
So let's talk about search.
Traditionally, search
is a ranking problem.
It's about getting
the most relevant app
at the top of the list.
And over the past year, we've
invested significant resources
in making sure that
Google Play Store
search is incredibly relevant.
But we also took a step back
and thought about new ways
to serve results on Google Play.
And so we came up with
this new experience,
where results, the
organic results,
are clustered around
topics and concepts that
are easily relatable to users.
And this does two things.
First, it helps users
narrow their intent faster.
They can easily browse,
scroll up and down,
and see which of
those subconcepts
are actually relevant
to their query.
Second, it helps
users understand
the range of options
and a range of apps that
are available on Google Play.
This experience,
obviously, only works
well for queries that
are very broad-- areas
that you can actually break
down into subconcepts.
So look for us to
continue to invest in this
and roll it out further.
From our experiments,
we have seen
that this experience drives
a greater total number
of installs from
more unique apps,
and very importantly, by
more unique developers.
All really, really good
things for our ecosystem.
So let's talk about
personalizing the store.
One of the insights we've
had is that there's really
no average user when you
have an ecosystem like ours.
We have over a billion users,
and they issue 400 million
search terms each month.
You really don't have a
prototypical user or interest
you can design for.
And in fact, if you build
a product for the average,
you will most likely end up
with a suboptimal experience.
So we invested a
lot in making sure
that the Play Store is
relevant and highly personal
to our users.
We think of it as
one user, one store.
And so if you're
a user interested
in hiking and fitness, you
may see this Play Store.
If you're someone who's
interested in learning
new languages and photography,
you may see this one.
And most importantly,
we've learned
that personalization really
drives an increase in installs,
and in fact doubles the
likelihood that a user will
install an app.
This is intuitive.
If you see something
that's relevant to you,
you're more likely
to install it.
But the magnitude
of the improvement
is what's really
interesting here.
So as you build your
apps, your experiences,
I recommend looking
at personalization
as a way to drive an increase
in growth, just like we did here
on the Play Store.
Finally, let's touch on
enabling exploration.
Exploration is different
than personalization.
Exploration tries to be
a bit more tangential.
If you've installed a
number of apps of this type,
I'm going to give you a few apps
that are slightly different.
And that's what we're
trying to grow and do
more of on the Play Store--
broaden users' interests
and help them explore more.
Over the past year, we've
launched e-developer pages.
These are home pages for
developers on the Play Store.
And what this does is, if a
user is browsing a developer's
app details page, they
will see a collection,
a rich collection, that
when they click on,
they go to this home page.
In here, they see a featured
app by the developer.
Then they see all of their apps.
They can then navigate
to one of those apps,
discover a similar
app, and so on.
This continuous cycle of
discovery and browsing
and pivots is really
healthy for the product
and enables exploration we
wanted to invest in more.
Next is Google Play for
Families, which we also
launched this year.
Families are an important
segment for Google Play,
and offering them a
discovery experience
that helps them find apps is
really, really important to us.
One of the neat experiences we
built is this character picker.
For example, if your kids are
obsessed with Superman or Dora,
you can easily come
here and see the icon
for that particular
character-- probably
the same way they're
dressed-- and find
apps and games and books
and movies that are
relevant to them very easily.
This is a really fun discovery
experience for parents.
Finally, look for
us to invest more
in context-based discovery.
Whether time-based
or location-based,
we'll look to aggregate
apps based on that context
and serve them up to users
just at the right time
or the right place.
Whether it's living
in New York or Mumbai
or whether it's the
weekend or the evening,
we'll start serving up more
of these apps to our users.
It's another way, again, to
drive exploration of the store.
Thank you so much for
listening, and stay
tuned to the Google Developer
channel for more content.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]